the Hungarian Empire was a multinational
state in one of the world's great powers
at the beginning of the 20th century and
I say multinational I really mean it
the Australian Empire was made out of
two main parts the Empire of Austria and
the kingdom of Hungary plus many
subdivision kingdoms duchies counties
Free Cities and one small part of
tangent city in China the Empire also
had many ethnicities and depending on
who you ask there were a nine to
fourteen different ethnic groups living
in the Empire and ruling over this
entire logistical nightmare was the
royal family of habsburg-lorraine with
the last emperor being the Blessed
Charles the first of Austria and the
fourth of Hungary the austro-hungarian
Empire was dissolved after World War one
in 1918 however before World War one the
Empire was the third most populous in
Europe had the fourth largest machine
building industry in the world and was
the third largest exporter of machinery
and electronic goods in the world
it was also geographically the second
largest country in Europe after the
Russian Empire at six hundred and eighty
four thousand eight hundred and forty
six square kilometers to put that into
perspective
austria-hungary was about the size of
today's New England plus New York
Pennsylvania New Jersey Delaware
Maryland Virginia and West Virginia
so what of the austro-hungarian Empire
were to be United today well as the
austro-hungarian Empire we're to be
United today it will be comprised of the
entire countries of today's
austria-hungary Czech Republic Slovakia
Slovenia Croatia Bosnia and Herzegovina
and parts of Poland Ukraine Romania
Serbia Montenegro and Italy as you would
imagine today so strongly Arian and part
would be just as diverse if not even
more than 100 years ago the Empire would
have a population of about 60 7.5
million people which would put it in the
21st spot on the world stage right after
Thailand but before the UK however
considering that the population of the
Empire was fifty two point eight million
people in 1914 it is a difference of
only fourteen point seven million people
in over 100 years which is much smaller
compared to UK France Spain's and
Italy's population growth since 1914
this small population growth can be
mostly credited to the economical and
political state of the area and the past
100 years
today's Australian Empire would be made
up of many ethnicities with largest ones
being hungarians at 16%
checks at 14% Austrians at 11%
Ukrainians at 10 posts at 8 selects
Romanians
cronuts at 7% respectively and all other
ethnicities are 4% or lower the charges
spoken languages within the Empire would
closely resemble the ethnicity chart
with Hungarian Czech and German being
the most spoken languages respectively
how are the Czech and Slovak languages
are mutually intelligible at around 95%
and both of these languages are mutually
intelligible with Polish at around 70%
the Balkans Slavic languages Slovenian
Croatian boostin and Serbian are also
mutually intelligible at around 81% and
to complete the circle all Western
Slavic languages are mutually
intelligible with the South Slavic
languages and Western Ukrainian at
around 50% each so that leaves us with
56% of the population being able to
somewhat understand each other at the
minimum at least bargain and 30% of the
population Czechs Slovaks polish and 16%
of the population Croats Bosnian Serbian
civilians being able to converse with
each other the religious makeup of the
Empire would also be very diverse with
41% of the empire being Roman Catholic
19% being Orthodox 14% agnostic or
non-religious 5% Protestant 4% Islam 2%
Greek Catholic and the rest 15% being
undeclared or other religions now that
we have the land and the people we can't
have an empire without an emperor or an
empress but thankfully we won't have to
look far as the former ruling family of
the austro-hungarian Empire the Habsburg
Lorraine are still in existence although
in 1961 Otto von Habsburg renounce all
claims to the Austrian throne as a
necessary legal condition to being
allowed to return to Austria for this
hypothetical scenario we will happily
give the Austrian throne to Otto son
Karl von Habsburg the current head of
the house of habsburg-lorraine now with
an emperor we need to decide on a
capital largest cities in the Empire
would be live live in Ukraine at seven
hundred thirty thousand people Krakow in
Poland at seven hundred and sixty
thousand people Zagreb in Croatia at
seven hundred ninety thousand bragging
Czech Republic at one point three
million the former capital of the
Hungarian Kingdom Budapest at one point
seven million and the capital of the
former but also if created today
undeniably modern austro-hungarian
Empire Vienna at one point eight million
people the GDP of the Empire would be
around one trillion two hundred two
billion two hundred and eighty four
million years dollars putting it 15th on
the world stage by
GDP right after Spain and before Mexico
the GDP per capita of Empire would be
seventeen thousand eight hundred and
twelve dollars giving the Empire 39 spot
on the world stage reading out trigger
public and just short of Greece however
the distribution of wealth in the Empire
would be very uneven as trigger public
and Austria alone would account for 53
percent of the entire empires GDP even
though they compose only twenty five
point seven percent of the Empire's
population
today's Australian Empire would also
have the fourth largest active military
in Europe right after Russia Turkey and
Ukraine respectively at around two
hundred thirty nine thousand active
personnel this would put the modern
Australian Empire active military is the
24th largest in the world
right after Sudan and before Saudi
Arabia Anna we have the land the people
the Emperor the capital city and the
military to protect it all how does this
modern Australian Empire going to be
governed well the Australian Empire was
a personal Union liberal autocracy
before World War one consisting of
Austrian and Hungarian states which were
co-equal foreign affairs and the
military came under joint oversight but
all the governmental faculties were
divided between respective states of
Empire of Austria and the kingdom of
Hungary so basically the Austrians and
Hungarians had their own autonomy to a
certain extent and the size of the
Slovak and Romanian populations and the
Empire were being largely discriminated
against but now 100 years later
concerning the Hungarians and Austrians
make up only 27 percent of the
population in the modern Empire it would
be advisable to give the Slovak in
Romanian populations their own autonomy
within the Empire under the Habsburg
Lorraine crown however with the new
autonomous regions in the Empire calling
austro-hungarian is quite unsuitable
therefore the last thing we should do is
find a new name for the modern
austro-hungarian Empire how about the
United Kingdom now I think I heard that
somewhere before how about the new Holy
Roman Empire even though it's not holy
or Roman or arguably an empire but the
Habsburg swear the historical kings of
the Holy Roman Empire
what about the United Empire even though
we're not really uniting any two empires
I don't know you tell me how would you
divide up and govern the regions of the
modern
Hungarian Empire what would you call it
what would be the main language what
would its flag look like and if you live
within the borders of the former
austro-hungarian Empire would you want
to live in the modern Australian Empire
I'm genuinely very interested to hear
your thoughts about it on reddit or in
the comment section I could not have
done this video without the animation
help from VI Slovakia and if you like
the animations please go check out the
channel by clicking here if you want to
see more videos like this in the future
please like and subscribe